[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Dancing with the Stars fans
I am lauren zima it is the morning after
the Dancing with the Stars all athletes
premiere and I have two people here who
killed it welcome to our studio
- Whitney Carson and Chris Mads do you
guys round of applause for these guys oh
my god straight straight water you guys
I want to thank you for being here
because I just learned these two were
rehearsing I was it until about midnight
last night midnight yep there is no
stopping we had the premiere last night
and you guys we're gonna break down
right now who got eliminated what these
two are gonna do from here to keep
killing it in the ballrooms so of course
leave your comments and questions for
them and I will get them here on our
iPad and we gotta knock it out because
there's a lot to talk about yeah how
tired are you guys we're ready freaking
tired about 30 minutes ago so I'm ready
to go for this like ask away
yeah that's the thing about the season
all athletes Olympians you guys are used
to training yeah are you feeling it I
know you guys know have the Dancing with
the Stars Studios we're kind of
everybody rehearsals is their rehearsals
rehearses is there a different energy
because these guys are so yeah there
definitely is a different energy I feel
like they're definitely more competitive
they're all very hardworking very driven
people so everything is just the energy
is just very competitive and everybody
has said the same thing you know
everybody wants to win everybody wants
to do their best they all want to be
each other out Chris is spying on the
couples I'm right back saying hello and
watching what they're doing that's be a
nas baby not spying that sounds bad it's
weird for like yeah from the athletes
side this is no different everyone's
like double elimination like all these
athletes really competitive and for us
it's like yeah this is normal like it is
competitive everything we do so but for
anymore because we have so much variety
usually in a season it's like sometimes
they're actors you know sometimes
they're singers so they don't really get
that competitive nature as with this one
it's like everybody it just has that so
it's it's kind of stressful really kind
of stressful of course Chris
you're the hot loser this is team move
it or lose it I want to ask you guys
real quick after last night who do you
consider to be your biggest competition
from here I'm gonna say Adam ya figure
skaters are really really strong
literally all the figure skaters are
gonna do amazing so I remember at Good
Morning America they asked the question
who here has any dance experience or who
took a dance lesson
none of the figure skaters raise their
hands and I'm like are you kidding me
like maybe it's not on a dance floor but
essentially like on the ice they have
lots of experience and it showed last
night so yeah they're definitely
bringing it like they're not holding
anything back and neither are we
I mean we're not holding anything back
either but I only have two and a half
weeks of dance experience here so I feel
like it's coming along yeah it's funny I
just watch like the intro video and
that's actually how I looked like two
weeks ago so I've come a long ways a lot
more to come but definitely the figure
skaters set the bar high and yeah that's
what we're aiming for so that's that's
why we're training till midnight because
we have to to catch up we have to put in
the time well that's what everybody was
talking about cuz I went to a couple
rehearsals with different partners and
everybody said the figure skaters are
the ones to beat but I felt like the
premiere was going to reveal which
figure skater I was really on top and
Adams you guys I mean yeah got that
entrance they came out with like those
wings behind him we didn't have any
props though cuz we went right away we
had a minute to change and go out so we
just us first off the bats transpose I
want to talk about you guys first let's
real quick go into who was eliminated
two couples went home in the first ever
double elimination on premiere so we had
Jamie and Artem heading home Jamie a
snowboarder of course and then Johnny
Damon baseball player and Emma so you
know they were on the lower score ends
Johnny and imma had an 18 Jamie and
Artem had a 19 but did that go the way
that you guys thought it would were
those the two you expected to head home
I did not expect that at all I feel like
I was really surprised I feel like Jane
you really had a grace about her I feel
like she had the potential to get a lot
better and same with Johnny I feel like
he had that personality that the Dancing
with the Stars fans really loved and his
routine was really fun I just I really
did not expect that at all did you no no
and it's it's tough because like we have
this athletic background but it doesn't
necessarily translate to the dance floor
yeah and to see everyone like come out
two and a half weeks is not a lot of
time to turn bricks four feet into like
like the cha-cha or the salsa or it's
like working part so it's it's tough to
see them go right away because there's
so much more but yeah Jimmy was so
graceful johnny was fun I know I didn't
see that coming I didn't see that coming
with Johnny especially because you had
that personality kind of like to me of
David a little bit I know me too yeah
it's a shock I was very shocked of date
of Johnny for sure because I like you
said like David did really well even
though he wasn't the best dancer he
still had a ton of fans backing him up
because everybody just loved his
personality and very very big family man
and so I was very shocked to see Johnny
too so I'm sad I mean I feel like they
would have been a really good asset to
the show but you know it's everybody has
to go and this time it's quicker than
ever you know so I wanted to ask you
Jamie and Artem had the waltz and I
think they were the only couple who did
how does it determined what those very
first dances you guys get are the first
dances really come down to the producers
they usually give us the first routine
and that's really just based off of
different things I mean where they want
you in the show what they think your
personality fits best and so for us it
was the salsa obviously your shirt
coming off and we think you guys like
your shirt came off and we're gonna show
this in a minute but your shirt came off
within 15 seconds I time oh yeah all
right out of the gate well I did wonder
especially because the stakes were so
high on the premiere and please let us
know you guys if you at home were
shocked by who was who was sent home but
the stakes were so high and for Jamie
and Artem to have the waltz which is you
know a little more of like a low key not
low key but it's different
it's not high-energy and fast-paced and
I wondered was that a little bit of a
disadvantage to them in this high-stakes
moment I don't think so I think if
anything it makes them stand out more
because everybody's was so high energy I
feel like theirs was very different from
everybody else so I don't I don't think
that they were a disadvantage I just
don't I don't know why that they were
the ones to go home but I don't know
well comments coming in James says you
guys did such a good job and Chris loved
your spray tan was it your first ever
hahaha yes it was it was great to have
that spray tan
we're just doing it all we're just
getting it out of the way great and
shirt off everything every rock stones
what are we done nine stone rocks rocks
rocks
yeah Whitney there was so much
discussion about voting about how it
would work in this shortened competition
again how did that affect how things
ultimately went last night do you think
I wondered if order would be part of it
but like yeah guys went first Josh and
Shana went last both safe what do you
think that played out like in terms of
voting in the East Coast West Coast
thing which I'm still not sure I totally
understand yeah it was difficult to
understand for me too because again
we've never done this before so it was a
live online voting only and it lasted
three minutes after the show was done so
I felt like I don't know going first I
don't know if it like gave us a
disadvantage because people didn't
remember or I don't know how that kind
of went obviously we're safe so it
worked but I just don't I don't really
know how it played out like I just have
never done that before but I'm just
happy we're here I guess yeah Rose thank
you guys nervous that voting and how
that was gonna work it did it did make
us nervous for sure we weren't we
weren't sure like how that was going to
play out and if the order mattered or if
our dances were gonna be good enough you
know because you have to grab the
attention of everybody right away
otherwise they're not going to vote so
it's like you want that something to
make people get their laptops out and
vote for you right so that's why we just
really pulled out all the stops I have
to be honest I was a little bit
surprised when we're talking about who
we thought was gonna go home yeah one
miss Tonya Harding who I
to her and Sasha's rehearsal she was so
sweet so lovely she ended up they put
her in eliminate in the bottom three but
shouldn't get eliminated but I wondered
how people would vote for her just based
on her history and whether they would
like her and Nancy had just been on the
show so yeah I was I was a little bit
surprised she didn't go home if I'm
being honest yeah did you guys have any
thoughts on that I think hurt her dance
though was beautiful yeah it really was
it really was exceptional so the judges
saw that and they rewarded her like so I
mean right off based off the scores
right they're like I feel like it's
difficult right like we're always trying
to get away from our past and I feel
like that's what she's trying to do it's
like she made a mistake and I'm an awful
mistake but she's trying to move on from
that and I feel like this was really her
chance to show people like who she
really is in a different light maybe
that's why I feel like you know maybe
people are trying to give her another
chance and and carry on but definitely
it's very controversial with her because
we I just I didn't know if she's gonna
go home like he said yeah well the show
is so much about what kind of story you
want to present so do you feel like
Tanya and Sasha really handled her whole
night right in terms of they really
played into the emotion and she got
emotional I felt like okay you made a
right move here because she's still
around you know yeah yeah that's gotta
be a lot of pressure as a pro like how
do I tell this story perfectly
especially right what competition
exactly especially when you have a great
story to tell it's like this was really
important for her this is the first time
she was competing performing in front of
people so this was really important for
her and Sasha did a great job kind of
like making that story her own and
having the people connect to her so I
feel like that was a really important
moment for her to really like get that
across so how is the voting gonna work
next week is it gonna be the same as is
there a new formula to figure out you
guys it's part of it's already over okay
so I don't think people realized that
you had to pick up the phones right
after the show ended in call last night
in this morning so it's actually the
same now so the only difference was that
first premiere night which was the live
online voting and then now it's just the
same so you can call and vote online the
same as always
and it'll reflect to the next week so I
think it ended 5:00 a.m. Eastern Time
today so timezone are we
yeah so that so that already ended in
that translates to the next week so
hopefully people can sit in their boats
so we don't go home next week you have
so many differently types of voting in
that like at one time so like all right
vote for us like online and then wait
like 30 minutes Glenn says Chris you
didn't seem nervous at all how did you
keep it together Gwen thank you this was
a hack question how did you hide those
nerves so B being first like so we're
doing this grand opening and we both ran
offstage to get dressed really quick so
we came back onto the stage about a
minute before we were about to go and
the stage was slippery so I'm like
alright we need to we need a bike wipe
this down so basically I had no time to
think I really didn't have time to be
nervous and so we did like one quick
practice of the trick and you see like
the time just ticking down you're like
all right 45 seconds yeah Wow this is
actually gonna happen all right and then
just you know really focus on the little
details and you gotta go I do have to
say I was very impressed with Chris
because the premiere night number one is
always very scary because you never know
how the celebrities are gonna react with
the cameras and the audience and
everything and number two going first on
the premiere is extra scary that's a lot
of pressure on him so I was really
really proud of him that he didn't mess
up too badly but shoots boiling room I
think like being in the moment like as
an athlete I love like the really
intense like experience that you have so
about 80% of this performance like
you're just in this like different world
where you're fully connected you're
engaged with the music with Whitney and
then the other 20% you're absolutely
terrified because 15 I don't know how
many millions of people are watching but
it's when we're going quick and we're
always you know always moving you don't
have time to get nervous but I remember
doing the slide and then like just for
that
second being like oh my god this is
actually happening like get up get up
get up like like use quick pause in life
jumps like there was a woman where you
did and I wonder if you can recreate it
for me something with your hand were you
like looked right at the camera and you
had some real attitude so much great
attitude and again we're in the office
we were all saying wow we didn't know
this guy was gonna be so awesome you
can't easily lays down on the job like
what is he I mean let me loved your
outfit by the way
and you guys Len said he was so
impressed he said you were terrific you
had style and confidence I was a good
notes from Len yeah they told you
Whitney that you had just jam-packed
that choreography you felt like this guy
could handle it obviously how did you
guys feel about your score because it
felt like you had to go first then
praise praise praise those night once
scores are always a little weird to me
because they give you all this praise
then it's like yeah well obviously you
know you've got to build somewhere so
they've got to have a starting point so
usually on the premiere night they're a
little bit lower than what you'll what
you'd want so I kind of expected it okay
so that's just kind of the name of the
game how it goes they've got to start
somewhere so name in the game so when we
have people asking this Kristen says
love you guys what song and dance are
you doing next week that's the question
what's your dance gonna be next week and
now that you ripped your shirt off and
did the lift what are you doing what's
what's the so I'm kind of just we're not
ripping any shirts off no pants sorry
but we three we're gonna do some things
a little bit slower a little bit more
graceful just something to put Chris in
a different light make him like the
leading powerful man so okay it's like
you got a just blazed through this four
week competition yeah yeah from Twitter
movie fanatic 3:19 says that they were
surprised by who went home loved your
dance why is this only four weeks was it
because of American Idol why did this
season end up being only four weeks I
have no idea yes Olympian weigh in on
um I I think it's pretty known I mean
ABC now hones American Idol and American
Idol was airing during a regular season
so they just kind of pushed it back a
little bit so we could both have a spot
on Monday night so you know what guys
I'm I'm in Sunday on Idol and Monday I'm
dancing I'm all ABC we're watching yeah
they're great exactly yes so want to get
into as well something that I just
thought was funny guys of course I got
to do my research go through your
instagrams before you get here I want to
pull up two of Whitney's Instagram
photos great because I was I was just
glancing through oh yeah and I did a
double take because I actually think
Chris and your husband kind of look
alike yeah yeah yeah brought up amongst
the three of you I literally know I saw
a few comments on my Instagram and I was
like oh kind of I don't know I don't
really see it I think it's just the
beard and the chin I'm so lighting it's
blinding it is maybe it's just the angle
but a good guy to look like both you
good-looking guys Whitney having been
dancing for so long I know your husband
totally gets the world you yeah what is
the best way when you have a new partner
and you're gonna be working with this
person a lot like do you sit down to
dinner howdy what's the way that you
handle look meet this person I'm about
to spend a ton of time with ya I always
really like to have my husband and the
partner meet so they get to know each
other and we're all just friends and we
get to get comfortable with one another
because yeah it's difficult it's like
I'm spending all this time with another
guy and he's like at first it was hard
he's like who's my wife grinding up on
now but now he told he gives it he's
like my number one fan he's always
supporting me like a hundred percent so
it's great he's like it's funny because
when we first got married he was like
can't just do your thing like whatever
and now he's like in my partner he's
like you should do a leap fair and then
why don't you spin there I'm like what
are you talking about like this is crazy
he's a mechanical engineer so this for
him is just like as he literally do
dance moves for me though it weddings
yeah get on the floor
Oh kind of yeah I don't it's funny it's
like I don't really social dance which
seems weird it's like you would be such
a good social dancer I'm like I don't
really social dance I don't know I think
it's just cuz I dance so much that I
kind of just like to chill no
I love it for some people dancing is
like their fun social thinking you're
like I need a break I gotta like I've
been dancing all day I just can't look
there's a million people are watching me
what's the point
no I love it but yeah it's just not not
for me and well I know you guys went
through a tough time this year I mean
losing your father-in-law and we so
appreciate you opening up about that how
are you doing we're doing okay as good
as we can be I think it's always hard
when you lose lose someone you're so
close to right but I think he was sick
for a very long time so we were all
really happy to see him just be peaceful
it was he was surrounded by loved ones
so we're we're moving on and moving
forward so yeah Sarah from Twitter and
you know you guys are on it you you know
what I'm about to say Chris you and your
girlfriend are so cute we had a little
Instagram your girlfriend was there last
night supporting you and Sarah has a big
question wants to know are you going to
be popping the question to this woman
she wants to know how serious you are
Wow Sarah how are you and your
girlfriend how long have you guys been
together together about a year now
okay so it is getting serious I just
moved in with her in Salt Lake City and
yeah like we're traveling around like
since the Olympics
nothing has ended where it's like okay
coming home after the Olympics not
coming home after the Olympics I guess
so I can't wait to get back to Salt Lake
City but yeah things are moving along
really well
so she sounds like a special lady
they're supporting you in the audience
and being by your side through all this
crazy stuff you're doing in your career
absolutely like again like I think
having someone who's really supportive
of you no matter what you do is so
important yeah especially in this like
we had no idea what was about to happen
but she's like go all the way when
Whitney do whatever it takes
yeah to help him win she's been a great
supporter so that's helpful for me too
cuz I'm like that's always hard when you
know your partner's loved ones or
whatever it doesn't really get it
because they're not in it yeah so she's
been really really great by the way I
heard we were talking about this right
before we started that you work a little
bit of a drill sergeant Whitney is about
your tactic with seven eight eight nope
that seven eight like don't give me time
to think
No
for a couple years now what have you
learned about the best way to approach
this competition overall you have a
different partner each time you have to
drill things in what have you learned as
a pro what I've learned is you have to
adapt to each partner right because they
learnt also differently and their minds
work so differently so it's some people
are very well but everybody learns
differently everybody likes sometimes
they break it down logistically
sometimes they need a visual so it's all
very different so I've had to like
really adjust my teaching and I've
learned a lot as I've gone through but I
think Chris is such a great student
where he's able to kind of he's aware of
his body which is another great thing
about having an athlete is they know
like how to fix things like if I say
roll your shoulders back they know how
to do that and they're very aware of
their body and posture don't sickle your
feet which we've really worked on also
want to ask you guys we talked about
biggest competition and we're gonna just
quickly yeah I really was gonna say
we're gonna go through a couple of the
other partners and just kind of talk
that through Kareem and Lindsay with the
lowest score unfortunately but man
tallest guy ever in the competition 7
foot 2 71 years old yeah what energy
what positivity and you know this I
guess is where maybe the fan favorite
and the crowd favorite voting comes in
like for sure who do you guys think is
struggling the most is it gonna be
Kareem and Lindsay how do you see this
going from here well I just think let's
look at the facts right I mean he's 70
years old right so he's not gonna be
able to move as well as some of the
other competitors but you know what like
you said he is a fan favorite and that
could take you really far so he's a wild
card to me because I feel like he has so
many fans and loves you and loves you
does such a great job of making him
shine and making him look the best that
he possibly can
so I think he's gonna be the wild card
like I think maybe his fans will take
him far I don't know also I have to say
this like yesterday I got there 9:30 we
didn't leave till 11:30 11:45 cream was
there pretty much the entire time so he
is 71 years old he
seven foot two and he is putting in the
time like it is exhausting for me
I couldn't imagine at that age like how
difficult this is so actually see him
like go through all this like I'm tired
I can't imagine what he's feeling so it
really is incredible like it's not just
the show there's so much that goes into
it so like yeah really even though like
you just see that there's so much that
goes into what he's doing so it really
is impressive how do you 29 29 so he's
got a casual forty years yeah uh Annie
says Kareem was so cute up there all
smiles he really was by the way looks
younger than he is man yeah he's with
his skin but he we also had you know
Adam and Jenna with the highest score of
the night a 24 how do you think Jenna's
doing in her first season as a pro this
is her first right this is her second or
second season yeah yes oh she was on
first with okay we're here with Adam now
but Adam yeah so I think she's doing an
amazing job I feel like she really knows
how to make him shine as well and that's
all the pros really can do is just make
our celebrities look the best that they
possibly can and they're so fun to watch
like I am a little bit obsessed with
Adam like I think he is just so funny
and so witty so I just I loved watching
them dance last night they looked
amazing they seemed to have such great
chemistry together
yeah I've been said I can't critique the
voguing too hard cuz it was too much fun
yeah Val came to support her in the
audience too socially yeah they seemed
very happy together so yeah by the way
guys we asked Jen about that you can
check it out et online.com she talked
about having her man in the audience and
have an orange blaze or the Tom Bergeron
just had to try on Mariah Allen were
close behind with a 23 for their salsa
they man is that woman hyper focused or
what I interviewed her and Mariah is
like a competitor she is so focused if
you don't let her casual talk like oh
it's no big deal it's fine like very
like slow but then on the dance floor
just like right to business right to
business
it's it really is incredible you could
tell that she's been competing her whole
life like that competitor right there
for sure and Alan shaken and shimmy Alan
was like okay I'll take my shirt off I
think we docked a design Adam was like I
got to figure out a way to get shirtless
because all these other guys did and so
now Adam will be sure now Jenni and
Keough had a 21 for their Foxtrot Gleb
Enrique with a 20 for the salsa so I
mean man this was a solid night of
competition I'm premiere wise did this
feel like to you as though wow we really
I mean nobody really felt like oh that
person couldn't even move out there no
this felt like the like fourth or fifth
week of a normal competition season like
this felt like it wasn't the premiere
but like we've been doing this for a
long time everybody looked so good like
I was genuinely impressed with every
single couple so it's it really is gonna
be a difficult season I feel like
everyone's just so competitive and
everybody's so good gotta stay hydrated
yeah I'm like just thinking about a
miracle hydration everything okay by the
way Jenna danced with Jake TOS and this
our commentary so helpful thank you guys
so then tell me kind of overall
especially on the pros side knowing that
you guys have to strategize differently
I feel like everybody is saying you had
to go hard right from the beginning now
do you think next week overall we'll see
more emotional dances what will we see
is it about putting out that different
side I think so I think it's always good
to give the audience variety right so I
think like we put Chris in a different
light where it was a little bit more fun
and loose and free and now we're gonna
put him in frame and we're gonna have
like this you know strong leading man so
I think it is a little bit more of an
the emotional more intimate side of
Chris which i think is good to have
different sides you know to show us
personality I know that's gonna bring up
the tears oh yeah so we'll try and do
that but I think as far as strategy wise
goes I think that's a pretty good
strategy something different and fun and
and something that makes it pop every
single week hmm
yeah all right leading man is there a
theme for next week is that there
there's no themes really this year's not
know so let's just go hard it's just go
hard to the paint
I guess
Whitney I know you're so busy of Dancing
with the Stars but you also have so many
other projects you're working on even
apps yeah I'm working on an app right
now yeah so it's a dance like work out
future app so I'm kind of just working
on that but it's basically where people
can learn how to dance from me so it'll
be like a video essentially a video
tutorial step by step step by step
breakdown of each dance style so it's
kind of a fun way to like get
interactive with my fans and just kind
of a personal way that I can interact
with them as well so that is such a
great idea
nope I've never done anything like that
but I know so I'm really really really
excited it's launching really soon we
don't have a date yet
but I've been working super hard on it
so I hope everybody loves it as much as
I've loved making it for them so we'll
see what happens but and by the way
every time I've talked to Julianne Hough
you know people like you guys are just
so fit and everybody wants to look like
and she always says dance dance is so
good for your body it works all your
muscles it does yeah yeah lots of
resistance and everything so not only
will you know if you want to lose weight
you can lose weight on it as well but it
will also help you feel mentally like
really confident and hopefully it's just
a fun way to get your hold up and active
Chris I'm sure you have an answer to
this that is yes but this competition Oh
switch it up like you gotyou every week
is this competition different than what
you expected I mean you've trained but
this is a different type of training how
is it gonna for you so far so I always
knew like there's there's a lot that
goes on with dance
obviously like people dedicate their
entire lives to this I know it's gonna
be difficult but coming in after the
first day I was legitimately scared I'm
like how am I supposed to do this this
is way harder than I ever thought it was
going to be not only do you have to
control all the little parts of your
body to music to someone else I wasn't I
wasn't expecting it to be that difficult
like to the level where I don't like
watching Adams routine last night being
like okay that's probably gonna take a
couple years but I'm gonna have to put
this into just a few weeks so I guess I
wasn't expecting how difficult this was
going to be it
is hard and we don't have a lot of time
to get this done so it's like yeah you
have I'm getting like literally from
9:30 to 11:30 yesterday and we're just
gonna have to do the same I wasn't
really expecting that but it's a 24-hour
go-go-go
non-stop learning process which is super
frustrating I never thought I'd be as
bad as myself dancing but it's a really
frustrating exciting difficult rewarding
experience well hey team move it or luge
it last question for you guys especially
because athletes kind of know how to do
this
injuries are always such a big thing and
this is a shortened competition is there
anything you guys are doing specifically
to make sure your bodies stay okay and
are the athletes like bringing some of
the pros some tips maybe like like
different techniques that you use to
stay healthy and safe yeah like you
bring that ball all the time and you
like roll out like I didn't like my
shoulder hurts and then you're like
really hurt some like all right let's
figure this out like okay all right
probably something from your SCAP and
then I'm like bringing KT Tape for your
blisters come on it's like complete
normal leg jargon like yeah some people
pick around the flat toys you guys thank
you so much for being here
of course make sure to vote and tune in
every week you guys to team move it or
luge it
we saw him shirtless and he's gonna
bring a leading man inside next week
we're all jealous of your girlfriend
Chris and everybody had a great day make
sure to follow these two on social media
and check out et online.com for all of
our interviews from backstage right
after the premiere last night okay thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]